Michels in Georgia Dave I was surprised
when another insurance agent told me
that in your book you admitted to having
whole life life insurance in your
portfolio
the insurance agent lied Michele I
didn't say that in my book I admitted
that when I was in my early 20s that a
goober from college came and sold us a
whole life policy and I was so stupid I
bought it but I cancelled it once I
learned mathematics what a scum believe
Berger his belief that it was help you
reduce taxes I had asked that if you
still had it and that was unknown
because I sell life insurance I want to
do right by my customers is there a
condition that someone should have a
whole life policy if so why no there is
not
whole life life insurance cash value
life insurance is the payday lender of
the middle class I've been screwing the
middle class for decades no one sells
whole life life insurance except
insurance people
no one believes in it in the financial
planning arena that doesn't sell it all
the independent thinkers and all the
people who do financial planning based
on numbers and mathematics believe whole
life is a ripoff and don't sell it the
only people who tell you it's a good
idea are people who sell it that's a
pretty sucky record really if you think
about it and this guy is a straight-up
freaking liar no I did not say in my
book I had whole life life insurance for
tax advantages I've written a bunch of
books and I really do know what's in
them because I really wrote them and
it's just simply not in there this guy's
a bonehead liar and you really should
avoid any doing any transactions with
him as far as whether you should sell
whole life
not there's only two kinds of people
that sell whole life life insurance
there are those that know that it's a
ripoff and therefore they're crooks and
there are those that are too stupid to
understand the mathematics and they
still continue to sell it or they've
just kept their head in the sand and
refused to look at the mathematics the
mathematics are pretty simple whole life
life insurance is roughly 100 times more
expensive so it's 20 times more
expensive I'm sorry so about a hundred
dollars a month buys you the same amount
of whole life life insurance that five
dollars a month buys you in term
insurance what does the other ninety
five dollars go to since you're being
charged a hundred instead of five
dollars for the same amount of insurance
it goes to build up a cash value inside
the policy which for the first three
years is zero what do you call that
front loaded heavy commissions
I mean if it's $100 a month premium that
means that they are collecting almost
$4,000 worth of commissions before you
make a dime I don't think so
and their Commission's a hundred percent
of your savings for the first three
years look at a whole life policy look
at the cash value build-up zero zero
zero first three years that's horrible
you guys that's not a difference of
opinion about you know a few percentage
points on how our mutual fund is charged
mutual fund charges five and
three-quarters percent for the ones that
do charge Commission these guys charge a
hundred percent for the first three
years it's unbeliev it's unconscionable
and then once you do start actually
having a cash value then you can
calculate the rate of return on your
money because we know what the insurance
costs because we can compare it to term
term covers the cost of the insurance so
we can figure out you got ninety five
dollars going in and then we can watch
it grow and put that into a financial
calculator and we can back out the
actual yield those of
who know how to do you know a financial
transaction with financial calculator
here's what you'll find the average cash
value policy will yield you net of all
expenses 1.2 percent on a whole life
policy 3.6 percent on a universal policy
and 4.3 percent net of all expenses now
they'll quote you ten and twelve and I
was other crap on a variable life and so
it's a horrible rate of return for long
term investing absolutely horrendous
rate of return on long-term investing oh
and then when you do build up the cash
value if you have a $200,000 whole life
policy and you end up with $50,000 in
there after you get past those zeros and
the horrible rate of return and you
finally end up with $50,000 in your
$200,000 cash value policy and you die
you know what they send to the
beneficiary two hundred thousand dollars
the amount of the insurance what
happened to your investment well they
keep it you have a savings account where
the first three years they keep all your
money after that they pay you one
percent and after that when you die they
keep your money this is a horrible
savings account it's a payday lender of
the middle-class it's absolutely
ludicrous so no I wouldn't sell that
stuff to anybody I don't even sell that
to an enemy I wouldn't want my name
attached to the lack of integrity of
selling a product like that
and if you're a whole life life
insurance agent and that pisses you off
good because I'm a consumer advocate I'm
not here for you I'm here for my
listeners and what takes care of them
and what serves them and I've
consistently said this on the air since
the first day I turned on this
microphone
I have never wavered from it one time
and I certainly didn't say in one of my
books you slimeball that I own this
garbage unbelievable unbelievable so now
now don't sell whole life you shouldn't
sell Hawaii
don't own whole life you should always
buy term life insurance for five dollars
instead of $100 do your investing
anywhere else crap if you put it in a
fruit jar you'll end up with more money
when you die than these people because
at least it'll still be there
it doesn't just poof disappear Puff the
Magic Dragon of Finance it's
unbelievable it's a horrible horrible
product hope I wasn't unclear